hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play 72 a horror
game made at the global Game Jam 2013 by
Janna Reinhart and Frederik honish okay
so that's enough of the introduction
let's get right into it it's made on the
Unity engine like some of the good games
here it actually disappears my mouse
okay
w guys need to move around nice ambiance
that's the look I like it when it
immediately drops me into a
disconcerting location and the sound is
there pumping into my ear balls hello
you got a throbbing heart
oh what a throbbing heart that's robbing
no I mean no no not at all okay so
there's something wrong with the crew
where they're dreaming Hey look this is
Captain America's room oh wait no that's
just whoa oh okay I gotta hold it down
to open the doors all the way so uh what
am I looking out for is there a monster
or some I might just raise II Jack his
strange glasses what's so strange about
him I wear glasses are they strange I'm
suddenly hearing whispering you guys are
hearing that right I'm not just going
crazy hey something seems to be wrong
with this excuse me just opening the
door okay where did that lead well that
led to where I started okay well why was
I trapped in that room well not really
trapped but why did someone close
or behind me what is that oh the figure
I thought I I still think I see a figure
but I think that's just the way the
hallways shape you guys saw that right
you guys saw that you guys hearing what
I'm hearing you're seeing what I'm
seeing any of these open a bowl anything
anything here
hello I'm assuming then I'm on a
submarine of some sort that's the only
thing that makes sense with all the
valve doors stuff like dad okay not
seeing anything important I can't say
that the objects in the environment are
all that high-res it actually reminds me
of a very old game made in the 90s you
know pre half-life stuff okay save save
activate glasses I'm crazy jack whoa
crazy jack coming down the hallways a
brewski yeah I knew I saw a figure what
was that okay that's really cool I gotta
say that's like you know you know how
some games have camera flashes so that
you can see but this is that's really
cool and really creepy
I'm guessing it's important not to run
into that guy I don't know if there's a
way around him I think I gotta go down
that hallway man that is cool that is
really cool
very clever mechanic bro I can't jump
I just gotta dodge his Patrol I don't
know I didn't dodge his patrol before
okay just like okay is it coming
I could see his shadow oh man okay yeah
that's right I'm just gonna follow you
brew nothing wrong about what I'm doing
okay in here whoosh oh man that is so
cool and I went in the wrong room
there's nothing in here
whoopsie-daisy not Zubat about me that's
not fair oh come on man all right well
good thing you saved right there I was
gonna
where is he where is he where is he
ah the area's okay he's gonna turn
around there he is
okay he's now gonna get me I'm too smart
and handsome strong so strong
okay going the right cord all right I
seem to slow down a little bit either I
slow down or it's a bit of the
perspective that goes Wonka fied if I uh
I push this thing I think I do slow down
though okay so we just left so if I go
this way I'll be able to go I'll be able
to go ha any monsters in here apparently
yes one there none down the hallway okay
okay one in there saw that well yeah but
he's just really cool because it's like
you know they're there but I don't know
they're there
okay that seems like a strange thing to
have on a sub just something that could
instantly destroy everything and
everyone aboard but okay whatever you
say man
how'd almost go by okay so that guy
seems to just be standing there in the
doorway he's not moving he's just
standing there
whoa honor who made these goggles I mean
I don't know if I'm crazy Jack I have a
pretty good feeling I'm crazy jack just
like this down the hallway but if I'm
not crazy jack then I might be that
doctor on the tape I don't think so I
don't know who I am yeah
what are you doing what are you doing
buddy what are you doing what do I need
to go aha
yeah go get me too smart I'm too
well-equipped I've been doing trunk
rotations at the gym super squats I call
them super squats what I do is I get on
the rack and then I hold one bar up like
this and then hold another between my
legs and then squeeze real hard and then
and give me a good burn in my loins oh
he was turning I thought he was covered
it get me I thought it was coming acaba
okay so I need to find this valve that's
gonna do overpressure to make the sub go
boom
where'd you go oh okay well here's my
chance well actually I don't know wait
hang on let's give us plenty of time
let's wait till he gets over here and
then go so that we have maximal time to
turn that door because I don't I don't
think it's saved hello
here we go here we go come on come on
there is no run McCann oh I could have
ducked in here I would have been fine
oh oh oh where you going oh you're just
standing there
good stay that way whoa whoa my heart
went will believe Oh buddy
why'd my heart go wobbly wobbly I like
it one below that guy is quick
that guy is fast that guy first I gotta
go I gotta go
he's he's not in front of me I don't
hear he's making a loop I gotta go I
gotta go I just got to have faith he's
not coming back because he's my close it
or I'm all the way back here it's not
fair
yeah man holy crap good they done good
on getting me
oh now I'm prepared I was just turned
blindly right into him this game is this
game I love the mechanic of this game is
really really unique because it's a
trade-off you know you can't really move
when you're doing it and you have to do
it regularly to keep up with their
position but they're also mobile so it's
really really clever I like it like a
lot oh how they got me okay I hate I
hate it a lot okay I'm gonna get it I'm
assumin in time of it so that I get back
to where I was before so that you guys
aren't just watching me go through it
again of course I won't cut out if I die
come on come on come on come on and I'll
be back in about okay I'm generally back
I just need to walk down this hallway
and open the valve but I he's like right
by being I've got dojo well bubbly okay
guys I'm back in this room again he's
patrolling like right there and I can
just gotta follow by him because he's a
quickie
he moves faster than I do see he's
already way down there so I just got to
keep going until I
get to the safe zone up ahead
maybe if I'm lucky if I'm not lucky I'm
boned I'm pretty sure I'm okay like
standing in this doorway I don't need to
close it because there's another one
right there
what does he just stand there what does
he do what do I do about that
what do we do about that he's just
standing there he's not very good I
guess I go to the right as much as I can
okay I got it
good good oh he's looking at me oh he's
looking at me oh why go on a big-ass
circle why what oh come on now with the
wrong way well where the hell is the
machine room I thought I went down that
way before
okay all right I've made a horrible air
or there's got to be another door that
I've haven't seen yet apparently okay
there he goes he's gone let's go it's
gotta be another door where the hell is
the other door though I don't know what
the hell I didn't see another dingdong
cam foul I think that could blow up the
ship hello open up open up okay there's
that guy let me try go if I go to the
left
that's the side I didn't come along
there go hey wait what's down there
remember I saw someone to the left you
think okay there are stairs down here oh
okay this must be very I was supposed to
go up but didn't go alright okay this
looks important
hello okay just see the Vaughn let me
jump down here oh oh
some sonic disturbances on that one okay
so there's one guy down that way but I
have a feeling I was supposed to go no
that wouldn't make sense either aha
here we are big ass valve [ __ ] ok
chunka chunka chunka t-minus six minutes
what am I supposed to get off how am I
going to get off the friggin boat how do
you expect me to go home if at all
you're honest you honestly don't expect
me to go home do you
where does this go ha ha mom is key
Bobby oh ok where is all of this
I didn't Scout an exit but I'm going
that way I didn't see before
ok I gotta go every layer somehow ok
they look at me I don't like that wait a
min have I been here before
I don't know it's a small ship but I
have I'm at a bit of a loss okay that's
dead end so up these stairs I go I don't
know where they lead Olli crap that was
close
okay I gotta go gotta go gotta go gotta
go oh that's uh no oh come on
[ __ ] what is this [ __ ] okay
five alright I'm back at the valve I'm
turning it and then I'm gonna try to get
out of here okay so I got some
complaints about some of this aspect of
this game you know but I will address
that after I finish it and I am gonna
finish it you son of [ __ ] that's right
run away where are you going again I
forgot okay there you go okay you keep
going that way
duck in here like vows
do not kill me you know kill ya you
freaky you freaky but I like that about
you
I just like it a lot okay continuing
forward where the hell I'm going I don't
know but hopefully gets off the shop
bloody hell
he almost got me okay go now go now go
now go now go now go no no no no no no I
don't think there was one in front of me
but I don't have time to check don't
have time to check okay wait a minute
wait a minute haven't I been up here
before
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute this looks familiar but I don't
know I don't see any monsters where does
this lead
aha
something new is that an escape pod
please tell me it is please tell me it
is is it yeah I escaped the nightmare
and banished them from the world how'd
they get on the sub in the first place
congratulations yay it done okay there
we go that was 72 okay it was great at
first very good very good very creepy
with the things hiding what you can't
see and you had to use goggles that was
very good I like that the mechanic was
solid
it was very trade-off he you know you
slowed down when you had to see him so
you didn't know where they come from
only Brahma had death very tedious very
tedious shouldn't be tedious I mean this
isn't a platformer game this shouldn't
be a platformer game with platform of
mechanics it shouldn't be you know you
have to be precise and stuff that's not
how that's not good for horror because
when you go through it again you feel
like I'm just playing one of these
impossible games where I got to get the
jumping your timing just right not good
for a horror game but the mechanic self
was great now I don't know how to make
it better but that's just my feeling
that totally broke out the horror was
not scared anymore which is kind of like
yeah okay so that's all I have to say
about that so thank you all so much for
watching the link is in the description
check it play for yourself
support the developers and as always I
will see you in the next video
so how the bag
I would be down